if you're working really really hard on
your business and you are not seeing the
results quite yet and you want to know
will that hard work pay off will you
become a success then this video is for
you
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that amazing thing
that you've got inside you first out
into the world that have a big impact
for yourself your and your community in
the world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna look at ten signs that
you're going to be really successful
even if it doesn't feel like it enjoy so
kicking us off at number one is you have
to have a vision for the kind of life
that you want with Tony Robbins how do
you create your life you get hungry for
something don't you who has done
something your life that once seemed
difficult or impossible and now it's
part of your life who's got something in
your life in this area say I how did you
do it you created it three ways number
one you decided there's something you
wanted so bad that you unleashed all
your desire you became obsessed with it
if it was a business or a car or a
relationship or a transformation in your
body if there's something you want sin
vision and now it's real it's because
you didn't just envision it you brought
so much emotion to it then now it's in
your life it was once a dream it was
once a goal and now it's in your life
how many have something like that in
your life now say I you may take it for
granted now hopefully not but it was
once just a vision may have seemed
impossible at one time so how did you do
it you started with a concrete vision of
what you wanted and you focused on it
continuously didn't you wherever focus
goes energy flows you envision something
you got clear about it and then you
start thinking about all the reasons why
you wanted it you got excited about it
so this is what's next for me now I want
this you may have dreamed about a
thought about and talked about it but
when you focus on something continuously
something magical happens
you get insights don't you you overhear
a conversation here's something you
wouldn't have heard if you didn't have
that outcome or goal that you wanted so
badly who's ever come up with something
obsessed about it didn't even know how
to do it and it just happened and it
came together who's that that experience
say I so why don't we tap into that
power now for your business in life I
love Tony that's a great high energy
clip to lead off this video so far that
was my favorite let's go to number two
you're using your signature strengths
with Mark Cuban I think the most
important is knowing your strengths and
weaknesses and knowing what you enjoy
doing you know if you look at it as a
job you've already lost it it's not
going to be your passion and you're
going to count the hours if you look at
it as something you love to do and then
you know what your strengths are then
you can leverage those strengths in your
business and in helping others and once
you recognize your weaknesses then you
can work with people that complement you
I mean every one of my businesses I've
had a partner who's very anal Martin
Woodall Todd Wagner I mean incredibly
anal people perfectionist because I'm a
slob you know I'm a big-picture think
about what's around the corner how is
technology going to change things how
can I change you know this industry and
you know making sure that there's
somebody there to make to dot the i's
cross the t's and keep me in the bass
lines um and you know recognizing my
weaknesses is just as important as
recognizing my strengths in my core
competencies and and you know having a
passion to do I love it so guys if
you're a slob make sure you hire people
that are anal focus on your core
strengths okay number three is you're
always looking for a better way to do
things Steve Jobs you know throughout
the years in business
I found something which was I always ask
why you do things and the answers you
invariably get are oh that's just the
way it's done nobody knows why they do
what they do
nobody thinks about things very deeply
in business that's what I found I'll
give you an example when we were
building our Apple ones in the garage we
knew exactly what they cost when we got
into a factory in the Apple two days the
accounting had this notion of a standard
cost where you'd kind of set a standard
cost and then at the end of a quarter
you'd adjust it with a variance and I
kept asking why did we do this and the
answer was less just the way it's done
and after about six months of digging
into this what I realized was the reason
you do it is because you don't really
have good enough controls to know how
much it costs so you guess and then you
fix your guess at the end of the quarter
and the reason you don't know how much
it cost is because your information
systems aren't good enough so but nobody
said it that way and so later on when we
designed this automated Factory for
Macintosh we were able to get rid of a
lot of these antiquated concepts and
know exactly what something cost to the
second so in business a lot of things or
I call it folklore they're done because
they were done yesterday and the day
before and so what that means is is if
you're willing to sort of ask a lot of
questions and think about things and
work really hard you can learn business
pretty fast that's not the hardest thing
in the world not rocket science it's not
rocket science no you can always count
on Steve Jobs to help you think bigger
shift your perspective think outside the
box of the norms that's one of the
reasons why he's up on my wall hopefully
you guys took something that to number
four is you are willing to take
calculated risks with Jeff Bezos how did
you go through making the decision to
drop it was a very good job and take it
take this chance it all seems very
obvious now write this many years later
that it paid off but at the time it was
not obvious no no it was and and I did
do a lot of soul searching I I went to
my boss at the time and I really liked
my job
and I told my boss I was gonna go do
this thing start an internet bookstore
and my wife had already told my wife and
she's like great let's go
and I I said so my boss is gonna do this
he's like this is a good idea so I think
this is a good idea but it would be an
even better idea for somebody who didn't
already have a good job and that sort of
made some logical sense to me and he
convinced me to think about it for a
couple of days so I went away I was
really trying to get my head around how
to think about this and I think for me
the right way to make that kind of very
personal decision because those
decisions are personal they're not like
data-driven business decisions there
they are
you know what does your heart say and
for me it was I could the best way to
think about it was to project myself
forward to age 80 and said look when I'm
80 years old I want to have minimized
the number of regrets that I have I
don't want to be 80 years old in a quiet
moment of reflection thinking back over
my life and catalog you a bunch of major
regrets and I think that regrets are
biggest regrets in most cases you can
murder somebody okay you'd regret that
but in most cases our biggest regrets
turn out to the acts of omission its
paths not taken and they haunt us we
wonder what would have happened I loved
that person and I never told him and
then they married somebody else I did
you know I didn't do this and so that's
the frame of mind that I put myself in
and I and once I did that once I thought
about that way it was immediately
obvious to me I knew that when I'm 80 I
would never regret trying this thing
that I was super excited about and
failing if it failed fine I would be
very proud of the fact when I'm 80 that
I tried and I also knew that it would
always haunt me if I didn't try and so
that would be a regret it would be a
hundred percent chance of a regret if I
didn't try and basically a 0% chance of
regret if I tried and failed so I think
that's a useful metric for any important
life decision
that's one of the best piece of advice
that I've ever heard and I've used in my
life and saved me in my first business
and gave me the motivation to go in and
be an entrepreneur that project yourself
forward 80 years old or maybe 200 years
old by the time we guys we get there and
just minimizing regrets so so so so so
so so so so important thank you jeff
bezos my favorite clip so far all right
number five is you're open to failure
with Kobe Bryant when you think about
your risk tolerance for failure how far
are you willing to fail well I mean
unfortunately unfortunately I've felt
quite a bit okay you know but I
understand that's actually part of the
process of succeeding I'm not one that
really believe in failure I believe you
have setbacks and you know you have to
learn from those you have to learn what
are those landlines that can be avoided
the next time
what are those pitfalls you have to
learn from that stuff so you know
welcome those things it's a part of life
but are you prepared to like really fail
it's something totally new like what if
you're just BC do anomaly UVC yeah you
know and then I work at it and then I'm
not as easy the next yeah you know
whenever it happens yeah listen uh my
first year in league on national TV 18
years old got shot five straight air
balls in the playoffs in front of
millions of people yeah I think my time
is pretty high yeah ya think I'm alright
right it's one of the most consistent
messages for not just athletes but any
anybody's had success you're gonna fail
you're gonna fail you're gonna fail the
more you fail the more you win the
people who succeed the most the ones who
had the most failure too I love it
alright the tip number six is you are
nice to people with Mark Zuckerberg how
many of you remember your first lecture
here at Harvard mine was computer
science 121 with the incredible Harry
Lewis Harry
I was running late for class so I thrown
a t-shirt and I didn't realize until
afterwards as I put it on inside out and
backwards my tag was sticking out the
front I couldn't figure out why no one
in class would talk to me except for
this one guy K X Jin he just went with
it
we started doing our problem sets
together and now he runs a big part of
Facebook and that class of 2017 is why
you should be nice to people that's
pretty awesome I hadn't seen that clip
before I love it I think I think doing
the right thing is always the right
thing finding ways to be nice to people
super important
thank you sucks for the message alright
number seven is you make time every day
to learn you went to Harvard and you're
dropped out have you ever thought how
your life could be better off if you had
gotten your Harvard degree I'm a weird
dropout because I take college courses
all the time I love learning company
courses and things so I love being a
student and there were smart people
around and you know they fed you and
they gave you these nice grades that
made you feel smart so I I feel it was
unfortunate that I didn't get to stay
there
but I don't think I missed any knowledge
because you know whatever I needed to
learn I would I was still in a learning
mode I think you see that a lot you know
Michael Dell dropped out Steve Jobs
dropped out the people who dropped out
it's not just about dropping out just to
go off and do your own thing but you
continue to learn in that process and
every single day you're learning and so
you don't learn just by going to
universities going classes you have to
continually invest in yourself and I'm
really glad Bill Gates brought up that
message alright number eight is you are
self aware with Gary Vaynerchuk I wish
that I could win on my looks but I don't
write like you have to know what you're
gonna win on and too many people want to
be a pop singer or a comedian or a
pretty face model and it's just not who
they are and too many of you are leaving
enormous upside on the table by trying
to force a narrative that's
Mantic in your mind versus what you
actually have yeah I could do so many
more things to build up my following but
it's not who I am I know the hacking
ways to get more followers to get more
people to know who I am but I'm a
businessman that happens to like
understand content a little bit so I'm
never gonna be followed by the most but
I'm also that means not gonna sell
things I don't believe in so if you
follow all the other entrepreneurs on
Instagram they're selling watches and
cash on bed and models and bottles and
private planes and I don't sell that too
because I don't want to get the cheap
followers or the cheap engagement yeah
and so when you really are self-aware
when you really know who you are what it
allows you to do is stay in your lanes
not do other things I can't produce the
kind of videos that my buddy Casey can
write I can't like it's just not who I
am
and so you sustain really my daily blog
it's just one exhausting episode of me
hustling 24 hours a day and honestly
eventually it's gonna be very repetitive
but I don't care that's my reality my
reality is I'm a workaholic who has some
talents but wants to show people that if
you work really hard if you want it then
at least she can get the most out of
yourself now not that you're gonna make
a billion if you work hard but the most
out of yourself so I think
self-awareness is imperative it's why I
put it in the new book no super
important message guides obviously when
I believe in it's why I wrote your one
word figure out you must work for value
go all-in on that it's where you're
gonna have success all right number nine
is you are self and passionate with me
so entrepreneurs are some of the most
stressed-out and most pressured people
that I've ever met and you know you're
out there trying to chase your dreams
trying to accomplish your goals you put
a lot of pressure on yourself to make
that happen
and I know there's a lot of external
pressures on you too you've got your
family you've got your friends you've
got society you've got the little man
who told you you couldn't do it all
these external pressure sources on you
to make it happen and to some extent a
little bit of pressure is good right if
you have zero pressure then you're
likely to be lazy and lethargic and
there's nothing holding your feet to the
fire is nothing they kick you into that
extra gear you have to raise the stakes
enough so that you want to go and do
work but too much pressure as well is
about
too much pressure will cause you to
break down too much rest will cause you
massive amounts of stress too much
pressure will make your business
software will make the quality of your
product or service suffer and I know
what you're thinking say well that's
easy for you to say Evan you know I've
got bills to pay
I've got mouths to feed I've got to make
some money so that I can keep my
business going and I get that and that
might mean that you take on a part-time
job just to keep your dreams going that
might mean that you slow down on your
goals on your dreams because you realize
that this is a marathon and it's not a
sprint and if you continue putting
massive amounts of pressure on yourself
then you're gonna run yourself into the
grave because it has an impact not just
on your business being able to be
successful but it'll cascade to every
area of your life and you'll start to
feel it in your health so the field and
your relationships when you are too
stressed out good stuff does not happen
so ease up a little bit on the pressure
and let things unfold
I like that clip that's from that's from
what two years ago I thought I did
pretty well I lost a little bit of
weight good so be self-compassionate
guys now last up number ten is you show
gratitude with Oprah Winfrey close your
eyes for a moment will you please and
breathe with me
just close your eyes and if you will put
your thumb to your middle finger and
gather your other fingers around and
let's feel the vibration and pulse of
your personal energy as you take three
deep breaths with me inhale and as you
exhale just feel the vibration energy
blood pulsating through your body
through you and another inhale
and another inhale and keep your eyes
closed and let's just think about this
day this day that you have been graced
to breathe in and out thousands of times
this day where many of those breasts
were taken for granted you just expected
the next one to come but the truth is
there's no guarantee that the next one
comes this day how you started your day
what your thoughts were this morning how
you've carried yourself through this day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences some
challenging some more life enhancing
that pushed you forward another day of
being here on the planet Earth as a
human being I just think about that
after all you've been through and this
day alone and the many days and years
passed how you got here to this
prestigious esteemed University the
choices you made that have brought you
to the
stay open your heart and quietly to
yourself say the only prayer that's ever
needed thank you thank you thank you
you're still here and you get another
chance this day to do better and be
better another chance to become more of
who you were created and what you were
created to fulfill thank you I love that
little guided gratitude meditation with
Oprah Winfrey that might be a standalone
clip she could sell that stuff I think
that's a fantastic way to end it we had
some good high energy points an end on a
moment of gratitude say thank you so
that's it guys that's my take on the ten
signs that you will succeed even if it
doesn't feel like it I think my favorite
clip was a Jeff Bezos wand is that that
one really resented me not living with
regret I'd love to know which one did
you guys like the best and why leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
I'm looking forward to hearing from you
thank you again for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one room is
much love see you soon full volume you
have the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details